Colin McAuliffe is still part of me so I
can't read I can't read include him in
the conversation of you know it's my
favorite Kody the golden will never go
away he sort of and in my skin topsy
turvy so this is a Mike Lee film called
topsy-turvy about Gilbert and Sullivan
who composer and writers of very popular
operators they were the first sort of
like pop popular musical forms actually
so I was playing the character called
John Doe ban who who was the Savoy
choreographer he choreographed all of
their operas now when you work with Mike
Lee you work with him for you don't just
get given a script and then you you play
the character you work with him and
develop the character over the course of
we had 9 months of rehearsals for this
part of what I had to do even though it
finally never even turned up in the
movie was I learnt to play the violin
entirely from scratch to a proficient
sort of degree because I it might it
might have been used I learnt the
choreography for for every one of their
operas and there were about 15 to 20 of
them and then you come to shoot the
scenes and of course you're not given a
script and it's so it's so that you do
these long you know you're in character
for hours and hours and hours of
everyday and classic Mike Lee is that
you you don't know how many days you're
going to end up actually shooting and
then you get you know you get called in
and you start shooting a scene and you
don't know how well that's going before
so after 9 months of rehearsal I
remember we I only actually shot that
character for two days which is the most
I've ever ever spent on developing a
character for so little so little time
in front of the camera it was a real
extraordinary time I wouldn't have
missed it for the world
but you you think wow I got a shot three
movies in the time of Graeme there you
know
the Lord of the Rings trilogy that mean
Lord of the Rings was obviously a big
turning point in my career because it
not only was it the the creation of
Gollum the character of Gollum but it
was it was the it was the beginning of a
long journey that is ongoing using
motion capture technology which is now
of course called performance captured
technology Peter Jackson one of the
things he wanted to set out to do was to
he said to me look no you could never
cast an actor to play Gollum you
couldn't you just can't cast someone to
we could that we could actually film we
would never be able to find that person
so we're gonna use this we're gonna
manifest him on scene on screen as a CG
character but we want an actor to be
there present for firstly to act
opposite the X playing Sam and Frodo so
they're not having to imagine it because
of course this was during a time where
normally CG characters were put in
afterwards and actors had to act against
the tennis ball on a stick but because
of the way that the relationship of
Gollum to to the other two characters
work he's he's often driving the scenes
he's often you know tearing them apart
he died the dynamics he's very
interactive with them and so there was
no way that that would work if they had
to imagine what this other character was
thinking when we started to work on the
film it was it this this technology was
sort of to one side because the first
part of the process of playing God and
was acting on set with with my fellow
actors on location in fact the very very
first day I have a shot on on Lord of
the Rings was the last part of the third
movie where Gollum is leading Sam and
Frodo up into Mount Doom and that was
you know because the principal
photography for all three films took
place together so we shot the all of the
films together over the course of a year
and a half so to come in and do I think
it was like scenes 862 or something like
that it was like right at the end of the
show you know three films and I'm like
wow okay this is where I'm starting I'd
spent a lot of time researching how I
was going to play goal and physically
I'd studied I was very influenced by
paintings by paintings by Francis Bacon
and Egon Schiele er and various
different artists I went through the
whole of the trilogy looking at you know
descriptions of how Gollum moves are
based in all other sorts of animals and
creatures you know I wanted to find
something that was tangible for
the power of the ring what it meant to
him and so for me what spoke to me was
this this notion of addiction and and if
the ring were present in a normal
person's life what would be the most
powerful thing that would control them
perhaps and again the way it would
physically rack his body and tear a tear
apart make him emaciated
when Peter started to watch me doing
what I was doing on set he said okay
what we're gonna do is we're gonna film
Andy and that's that we're gonna film
him on set see how you know copy exactly
what his movements are and then work for
any sort of close-up CG shots which are
just gonna Gollum which aren't fully
interactive with the other actors or the
environment we'll go back onto the
motion capture stage and we'll capture
will shoot plates and will Andy will act
on his own in a motion capture studio
and it was really exciting and really
really thrilling and that was my first
sort of epiphany of what performance
capture could do and then that that
technology evolved over the course of
the three movies and we were then able
in the last movie to actually take the
performance capture cameras that were in
that little volume and put put them
actually onto the sets
13 going on 30 there's a really moving
script it was a great cast Jennifer
Garner Mark Ruffalo I mean just such
terrific actors and an amazing director
Garry Winx sadly no longer with us who
had a really great take on it which is
to make it although it's such a high
concept piece you know girl-girl sort of
becomes a 30 year old version of herself
and it sort of had this really powerful
believability it she gets to work at a
magazine and he and I was playing the
editor and there's a sequence in it
where there's a party sequence where
they they find out the two lovers
finally get to kind of see each other
across a cleric crowded dance floor and
come together and I got to I got to do
the the Thriller dance as this a kind of
rather uptight editor thinks his party's
going down the drain and it's all gonna
be a shambles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then suddenly that party comes to
life in this dance and he relaxes and
lets go and because you know he's quite
flamboyant and yeah and I got to do the
Thriller dance and moonwalk
King Kong so King Kong was it was a huge
journey of discovery in lots of
different ways really when we started
working on the movie and Peter asked me
to play the role which was right at the
end of Return of the King
it was literally a moment way he said
and I was thinking well this is the end
of my journey with performance capture
I'm going back to my job as a regular
actor and that what an extraordinary
experience but I didn't really expect it
to go any further or all the technology
to go any further I thought it was just
really built for that so I went about
researching gorillas in a great into
great depth I went off to Rwanda and I
studied mountain gorillas with the Dian
Fossey gorilla fund International and
learned about their vocalizations learnt
about you know how you know how they
behave how they are socially how they
interact how they beat their chests how
you know just just just everything about
about how they were so all this research
had done all this research
when went back to Peter and said I
really want to play King Kong you know
unlike the 1933 version which is what
inspired Pete to make the movie because
he was such a huge fan of that movie I
think we should make him more like a
more gorilla like than but beast like
for the first period of the shoot was
the Wiz principal photography in the
classic sense Naomi Watts was was being
filmed all her angles are being shot and
I was off camera for months being King
Kong off camera for her and we used to I
had a gorilla muscle suit I was placed
up on ladders and podiums and scissor
lifts and to get the right eye lines
where no he could then act opposite me
and then sometimes I'd be really really
intimate and we'd be really close and
she could reach up and and touch my face
and that would be the equivalent of like
touching Khan's nose but the intimacy
was was created because we were able to
really look into each other's eyes and I
and properly act opposite each other at
the end of principal photography I then
did two months of doing all the capture
for King Kong and and so what we used to
do for that I was I was able to have
Naomi's performances of the selects of
her takes that Peter was going to use
for me to act against and an hour to
have have her in a little clamshell
monitor that I could literally look down
and then they were capturing my facial
expressions as I was playing opposite
this tiny little image of her so really
and I was emotionally recalling the
scenes when we played them together and
so it was able to be you know connective
in that way the other character I played
was lumpy the cook who's this sort of
kind of you know self-serving bit kind
of doesn't want to endanger his life in
any way he doesn't want to go and rescue
and Erica's you know he's gonna be it's
gonna all end in you know trouble Peter
wants to recreate the scene this famous
scene which was missing from the 1933
version called the spider pit sequence
and which was never put into the movie
because people people found it so in
fact it was put into the movie but there
were none taken out because people
thought it was too scary and so people
wanted it back in of course and because
Pete's terrified of spiders he wanted to
you know visit his fears by by creating
this spider pit see because with these
horrendous insects and creatures I mean
it's it's it's really dark
I remember when we shot it basically we
had to have like three or four actors
big stunt guys in in green suits who
were holding my arms holding me back
hold you know pulling pulling it back
and then and then literally sort of like
trying to envelop me and and sort of
lumpy lumpy goes out trying to fight to
the end when I saw it in the movie it
was just like one of the most disgusting
deaths I think I've ever seen on screen
which traumatized my children forever
actually the prestige to work with Chris
Nolan was amazing I had always been a
big fan of his work and this script I
just I remember reading the script and
just thinking wow this is an amazing
story
you know it's beautifully crafted the
great wonderful David Bowie was in it
and I had all you know pretty much all
my scenes with him and so I felt so I
mean I was so excited to work with with
him and he was playing Nikola Tesla the
great scientist these things never quite
work as you expect them to mr. angio
that's one of the principal beauties of
science and David was so hilarious I
mean he's such a comedian like and so
unassuming and friendly and
down-to-earth he's like it's hard to
quite imagine the superstar that he is
went when when he when you're in his
presence because he's very very humble
he really made me laugh a lot because he
used to he was doing Serbian accent for
Nikola Tesla and he used to say Andy I
think my Serbian accent is a little bit
like Inspector Clouseau
he really put himself he really is to be
was very self-deprecating in a very
amusing way there's a sequence which is
a lot to do with with these cats that
are made to disappear and you don't know
where they've gone and is it magic or
you know it is it literally sort of
transferring energy and and we so he had
a lot of stuffed cats and he stir the
yeast used two puppeteers I'm a play
with them and sort of make him come live
and he was just great fun and we did a
struggle to keep straight face a lot of
the time sex and drugs and rock and roll
we wanted to tell a story about Ian that
wasn't a sort of sort of and then and
then and then biopic you know it was
like a more of a snapshot of the energy
of who he was and it told in a very sort
of pop art way he was such a childhood
hero of mine I mean he really when his
when his hit song him you the rhythm
stick came out I was fourteen years old
and I hadn't heard anything like ever it
was just it was it was everyone at
school was singing it every you know it
was just like it was a big hit and my
first day of shooting on that was
actually recording there was the band
Lee used to play with which became very
famous or we called the Blockheads and
and they had huge hits like sex and
drugs and rock and roll him unity rhythm
state I mean countless countless numbers
I had to record all of the songs for the
show with the original Blockheads which
was one of the greatest experiences ever
and I went in there thinking if these
guys don't like me I'll think I'm doing
a really bad impersonation of the person
who's died who was the leader of their
band I'm gonna get absolutely killed
here you know I started from the first
song and I could just feel them well you
know they look they launched into it and
fortunately the first song didn't go too
badly and then I feel relaxed and got
into and they were like by the end of
they were like wow god it's like having
any the room
[Applause]
[Music]
our insane physically I had to kind of
learn to walk with a caliper and swing
you know throw the weight from my hips I
had to you know I built I built I did a
lot of work on one side of my body so
it's at the other side was sort of
fairly inactive and I the worst thing
was in D&D didn't have any hair on his
body and I'm quite hirsute and I had my
entire body waxed which was I think the
most painful thing I've ever done in my
life especially by the person they were
had it done by who'd never done it
before in her life and I just got these
images of her putting hot wax on my body
and then pulling and yanking and then
getting stuck and literally having a
feet up on the bed and punking you know
it's just like I was raw at the
oscillatory red raw at the end of this
experience I thought I can never do that
again the Planet of the Apes it's very
rare that you get the opportunity as an
actor to play to play a character all
the way through from birth to death in
effect and over the course of three
movies and to see every aspect of that
character's life in a way condensed and
telescoped into into movie times and not
only that it's not just a character kind
of getting older it's a character that's
evolving evolving physically evolving
his intelligence is evolving because of
the drug that he was being given I mean
it's an amazing sort of a really
incredible journey for a character so I
think I think that's the one that that
really that ultimately means the most to
me I was
the most difficult scene I think of all
of the the city of all of the movies
actually was probably the scene the
final scene with with Woody Harrelson's
character the colonel who who by now at
the end of the movies has contracted the
disease and he is becoming muties mutant
mutating and he wants to kill himself
and sit and Caesar now has his moment
where he can exact revenge after this
whole journey of trying to track down
the killer of his family everything he
believes him is is put into this one
scene and there's a range of emotions
that he goes through and I think that
was the most challenging scene that I
think I've got a shot actually to get to
to get right The Adventures of Tintin we
just explored sort of all different
versions of filling that kind of
bombastic nature of him and yet finding
the finding moments where he can be sort
of soulful and lost and sort of drifting
away but but so Archibald haddock is his
name we settled on this this Scottish
accent because it just he just sort of
worked really well against the fact that
his ancestors were we wanted to make a
character that felt like as far away
possible possible as possible from from
his ancestors that were more royal if
you like so that there was a real you
know the fortune had been lost and the
family had got sort of pushed further
and further he ended up you know they
ended up migrating to Scotland and we
built a backstory for our version of had
it the entire film's motion capture in a
studio there so there was no there was
no there was nothing shot on-location it
was all it was an entirely CG world
Stephen was looking in avert through a
virtual camera at all of the
compositions where so what he's looking
at as a lit rendered beautifully
constructed shot with live characters
moving around inside it and then what we
see in the real world is is actors in
grey suits head mounted cameras walking
around a you know
a sterile environment The Hobbit the
difference between the Lord of the Rings
process and and The Hobbit which was you
know 10 years later was this whole
journey of a motion-capture becoming
performance capturing by that we mean
capturing the face at the same time as
the body and audio all at the same time
so you only have to do it once there's
no sort of going back and repeating the
process so me acting opposite martin
freeman that was not going back and
having to do it a second time it was all
on on the location or that on the
amazing set that they'd built for the
McCollum's cave alongside the
technological advancements and they kind
of at the resolution of the cameras and
all of that stuff which makes the
fidelity of the performance a lot
stronger there's also an incredible
amount of knowledge that was learnt by
the animators who over the course of 10
years had worked on other films like
King Kong on Avatar and Tintin but
there's also rendering changes in the
way that the skin textures are rendered
and wetter who are the most brilliant
visual effects team who created Gollum
in the first film then in the Hobbit
trilogy had really mastered a sort of
you know how to make the skin really
translucent how light reflects off the
eyeballs so that you make them much more
readable and much more lifelike and the
whole way and I is constructed digitally
to reflect the patina to see that the
dilation of pupils and how light affects
there it all this was all knowledge that
had been built up since the first time
we did it
the last Jedi the character of Snoke was
when I started working on it with JJ was
a really elusive difficult challenging
part to get my head around there wasn't
really like a finished version of what
he was going to be like so he it was
gonna really come from what we were
doing you know I mean in tandem with the
designers but but it was it was like
we've got a blank canvas here the more
that we talked about it the more that we
got under the skin of it the more you
know we tried out but gosh you know so
many different vocal qualities for him
and and then it just settled down we got
to simmer and this sort of this this
character that was that had that carried
a lot of physical wounds this properly
manipulated can be a sharp there was a
vulnerable look to him and a sort of
emaciated look to him but that but then
this this malice and control and you
know this deep hatred that sort of came
out of what we were exploring I suppose
Avengers age of Ultron that role came to
me in a very bizarre so a roundabout way
I I at the Imaginarium which is the
studio motion capture studio that we
have in the UK which basically is a
service providing studio as well as a
sandbox to explore the future potential
of what performance capture can do in
all sorts of different arenas who worked
on age of Ultron that was that was one
of the first films we actually worked on
where we were assisting Mark Ruffalo to
become the Hulk and doing the capture on
set Joss Whedon just turned around to me
one day and and funny enough eats he
really was a big fan of sex and drugs
and rock and roll and he and he just
said Andy I've just really I've got an
idea and I don't know if you'd be up for
it but there's a there's a small part in
this film but you know it's a really
great character as Ulysses core a really
light idea of playing this mercenary
this tough mercenary who's kind of
answerable to no one so morally
ambivalent and morally reprehensible
so it's so excited yeah well I'll do it
and it was only there was a it was a
small part in our trumpet it was a
really quite nice scene cuttlefish
deep-sea fish they make lights disco
nice way to hypnotize their prey and
that then you know branched into into
coming back into the black panther which
was one of the most extraordinary
experiences the black panthers getting
to play a character in such a
groundbreaking culturally important
really exciting energy onset Raikou glee
just knocking it out of the ballpark and
and a great cast of actors who were all
knowing that they were part of something
really special yeah it was phenomenal
and I like I loved where Ryan Coogler
was pushing me just to be really sort of
go as far as I could with the character
everyone says that and it um I don't
know what it was I think I was helped
out by the costumer
you know having a sort of a tight
waistcoat and a and sure I did I do work
out I keep fit but I wasn't I wasn't
like you know you know on steroids or
anything I'll kind of or pumping for my
life I think a lot of its to do with the
way that I was carrying myself I guess
Mowgli legend of the jungle I read this
script and I just thought this is a
version of the story that that I just
haven't seen before and it goes right to
the heart of the book and the tone of
the book and that book is a lot darker
and it's a very complicated complex
journey of an outsider of an outcast
who's trying to form as he's realizing
that he is you know not part of the
family that he was born into other
versions in a way they they sort of they
get very caught up in you know rightly
so as a piece of entertainment in that
antics of the animals and
you know in 1967 famous Disney Animation
which we all grew up with and loved you
know the animals are all singing all
dancing you know one wonderful
characters but they they seem to be at a
distance from the source material so so
that's why when I wanted to direct it I
wanted to kind of do a version which
really delved into the Kipling world and
and and set it in India and also our
version of the film really a third of it
the last act takes place in the world of
mankind and other versions tended to
avoid that you Bagheera will hunt you
and if he catches you you fire wanted
him to be this this brusque kind of yeah
yes drill sergeant he was pushing really
pushing Mowgli hard for his own good and
it was it really represents a sort of
tough love rather than a sort of
all-singing all-dancing hippie-ish kind
of hit home honey eating bear animal
farm we're making it with Netflix and we
have a wonderful cast lined up to do it
we are in the middle of writing at the
moment and refining the script and that
will be shooting it around about
probably hopefully over this time next
year